even though you had already made a
feature what were some unexpected
challenges that happened with the second
film of violent man
you know I it's the same things that
happened on on any film set right
there's just you know you you improv
assign things change the scene takes a
different texture your your lights not
right you gotta wait you have less time
than you thought you would
the unexpected challenge on a violent
man you know the fight scenes were
difficult the fight scenes were
difficult to shoot I mean I prepped a
lot and and we shot I mean I shot like
seven scenes of the film like with just
like my buddies and co-producers and
like Thomas and just and I shot lists
the mall and then I shot them before I
got on set intentionally so I could like
work out what shots it would need which
it's I don't so no matter how much you
prep right and then I cut the scenes
together and I was like I you know I
really don't need this shot and really
don't eat that or this one will play so
I don't need to spend too much time on
it and so no matter how much you prep
right like things will always change
when you get on set to a degree I mean
we prepped a lot in those scenes went as
smoothly as possible
but you know it's I was also telling uh
I I think that the one obstacle is
telling so many stories at one time
wildin blues a story of one guy and this
was a story of one guy cops bad guys
this that and all the kind of storylines
had to interweave and keep it on the
edge of your seat at every time so that
was an obstacle but I think that it it
does well I think the audience will be
happy did you have like a fight
coordinator I did his name was John
Louis he played one of Ty's best friends
his name is Jamison in the film oh yeah
he's the actor in the movie so it was
just sort of the unexpected turns of you
thought a scene would go this way and
then once you saw from the camera well
the fight courting the fight the fight
coordinating was like pretty
on point you know and the and all of our
shots are on point but you know your
actors get exhausted you know their I
mean you've got Thomas Jones like it's
running back pro of all time
it's got Chuck Liddell fight you know
UFC Hall of Fame so these guys are gonna
go
they really are extremely athletic and
they did not hold back on their
athleticism at all through the fight
scenes so you're kind of on the edge of
your seat like oh my god like we're
doing this is one of these guys are
gonna get hurt and you you'd say and it
looks so real because part of it is real
you know and like I'm on board to do
that as long as my actors on board and
they were so it's like kind of like
every time you you'd say action your
heart would race up until you said cut
and then you'd still be pounding for
like five or six seconds you're like
you're okay you're okay you're really
okay you're really okay and then they're
like yeah that's ready to go again
so for me watching the fight scenes I'm
not like I'm not a fighter so I'm just
I'm just a director I'm just trying to
make the scene look as good as it can
said that was uh just energizing every
step of the way are you through the
distribution phase with the film or
there's another leg to it which is going
to be online
no I comes out theatrically and VOD the
same day so just like I'm done yeah I'm
really excited are you already planning
something else my next film yeah I got a
couple things on very cool now so that's
kind of it seems like now this is
becoming a pattern one kind of ends and
the other starting and that's how you
kind of see it going knock on wood
[Laughter]